what's up party people welcome to the
honest trailer commentary for Joker this
is a show about a show that you've
hopefully already watched on this same
channel and if you stick around we're
going to talk about the Joker our
deepest most innermost most twisted
thoughts yeah then we are going to show
you some deleted scenes respond to
questions and comments from viewers like
you and T's next week's honest trailer
I've got what a society I've got with me
today I've got nan lon unlike some
honest trailers this seems like the
perfect one to discuss this movie Joker
stuff let's do some Joker stuff they did
yeah everyone was gonna go do Joker
stuff
yeah yeah there was a real concern for
like a week when it came out I was a
little concerned that Joker stuff was
gonna go down sure
yeah very very disturbing movie well I
thought everyone else is fine you can
say this about literally any movie that
comes out in America but there were some
mass shootings in the lead up we don't
need a movie to come up with fire PG
terrible thing yes as as a group who has
who has gotten some death threats from
various Joker's in Joker avatars in
addition to you know a couple of motion
America like I got it like I was like
yeah okay I get the idea that some
people would be a little like right like
now we need this movie now but also once
I saw it I was like oh yeah no I don't
think this was gonna well so was a lot
of like before people had seen the movie
but what we knew the movie was coming
out there was a lot of speculation as to
what might the movie be about or well
the sort of themes are gonna be a lot of
wrong
which is weird to me though because and
we can get into this but when you're
like we're doing a movie about the Joker
I should know what the themes right
ideas and things in that movie are or
maybe you didn't do like a solid movie
about the Joker
well that's the thing I mean Todd
Phillips has said you know the quiet
part loud that like he's just making a
cool 70s throwback movie that he's gonna
call the Joker and get made by a studio
ha ha that's the ultimate Joker stuff I
think his own words you say he's gonna
like sneak this movie into theatres by
by making a comic book well no like
Joaquin if you go back and watch his
acceptance I think it's for the Critics
Choice Award he was just like yeah we we
fold a bunch of people they giving us
money to make this movie about mental
health they're not hiding what what's
happening with it you know and yes I
love this movie I think I like this
movie ally did my best to distance
myself from the hype surrounding it to
just watch it including Todd Phillips
Todd Phillips isms and just go in and
watch as a movie I really like this as a
counterpoint to a Batman movie I think
this actually I like it the best when I
evaluate it as a DC movie as a
comic-book movie as a movie about the
clown with magic gadgets it's just like
the king of comedy or it's just like
taxi driver those are masterpieces like
the fact that it's not that good to me
is not a knock on it well no it's not
being as good as so the best movies
weren't says he's ever made I mean that
98% of other films don't match up to
that yes mark yeah I mean I guess I get
where people were like oh it's a
Scorsese ripoff like things necessarily
Scorsese ripoff it's good a lot of
similarities in some aspects but I yeah
for me it's all Joaquin Joaquin is the
one that like even as I was watching it
again because I saw it the first time it
really kind of got to me but the second
time I watched it after I'd seen it and
knew what was coming and that kind of
wore off a little bit like it didn't
quite hold up as much to me on a second
viewing what did continue to hold up and
I think will always continue to hold up
is Joaquin's performances perform
it's likely to be an oscar-winning
performance and well deserves because he
is he is phenomenal yeah I mean like
what might be knock on it and I I did
the first time I thought I really liked
it I still like it I think technically
there's a lot that's great going on it's
a great looking movie the score is great
Joaquin is great but I think that you
know one of the criticisms that comes up
the second and third time through is
it's a lot of great work being done but
I'm not really sure what the movie is
speaking to like taxi driver King of
Comedy when you're done you feel like I
get what the take is on this person in
this world and like I get kind of what
Scorsese and De Niro are sort of saying
with this with Joker it feels like
they're throwing a lot of ideas out
there but none of them is like VI D
along the theme was very clearly what do
you get yeah crazed loner in the trailer
it's like there's the mental illness
there's like he was desperate for a Fame
and attention he always felt like nobody
sort of pay attention there was there's
also like cutting social services and
like sort of class movies there's like
two two tracks that the movie is going
on for me this is my reading of it is
that there's the society way attractive
it's on which is like oh we're we're in
this increasingly atomized society where
the top the people at the higher rungs
are [ __ ] down on the people at the
bottom there was that point message
being made and then the Joker on a
character level it was a man it was like
a true tragedy and like the Aristotle
sense of like this guy's flaw is he so
isolated and most movies would have him
overcome that and find connection and
grow and or just make some kind of
reaching out to other people but it's
him being more isolated and
disintegrating more and more which we're
not used to seeing I don't think we're
used to seeing tragedies even like
movies that are dark and gritty there's
some of the character at the center of
it evolves in some way positive or
towards something this guy was just a
somebody falling apart which we don't
see very often yeah I and I get that
and also really like Joaquin's
performance it's kind of the only thing
that holds the thing together for me and
i agree with you on the tragedy thing
we're not quite used to them but i feel
like even in solid tragedies whether
whether you're talking about Oedipus Rex
or Breaking Bad your protagonist is
still active it's a tragedy but they're
still actively making choices ending a
fatal flaw that's like right your tragic
fate is brought about by he kind of just
gets pushed along and then shoots
someone and then the movie ends like so
that's where it falls for me and I like
this isn't a situation where it's like
Suicide Squad where I'm just like let's
take a big old dump like this is more of
just like I'm like oh here's where this
doesn't work for me which is fine yell
at me in the comments but as like a
Joker movie it it's it weirdly doesn't
work because he's like oh I I don't have
an agenda and I'm not political were
like the Joker would have an agenda like
a guy actively choosing that Joker
lifestyle would would choose to like
take advantage of all of these
combustible elements and stuff like that
for his for his own gain because he's
the Joker and he's a villain and that's
what he's supposed to do that's like
because that's the tragedy you want to
root for this guy to not be Walter White
but he's gonna end up being Walter White
anyway right and then it's like a non
Joker movie it's it's still that it's
then it's just like slow just it's like
grave of fireflies which is beautifully
done but like that movies just a slow
descent into to kids dying and it's like
sure okay yeah as a counterpoint to a to
a Batman film it's just for me was a
really good flipping of the tables where
it's like Batman also birthed in tragedy
also kind of a loner and and
disconnected but he and he's also
someone who thinks society big s society
is messed up but he takes that out on
the people below him he's a billionaire
who beats the crap out of people lower
on the socio-economic
rather from him I guess random people
he's pulling off the streets who's
deciding who's the criminal Dan Batman
corrupt and the city would be spiraling
out of control obviously they're
extending services all this I just
thought it was an interesting reversal
of perspective where Joker same sort of
emotional maybe societal origins as
Batman but he directs all that rage all
that alienation up the chain of society
up towards the people above him where
his Batman is punching down see III get
to the trailer eventually I promise get
your video starts at blank comments
right I always started in the second
time it even struck me more it actually
was he and it might just kind of your
point Joe about him being kind of kicked
along but it's like he doesn't really
start anything he he does what what
happens in his life is not like he
doesn't kill anybody to start a movement
right
he's just spiraling and the world around
him is growing more chaotic and more and
they take inspiration that he doesn't
necessarily mean for it for it to be
taken which i think is sort of when it
culminates with him just sort of for the
first time taking inventory of just like
oh wow like look at look at this but
yeah I think it's I agree it's it was
always a bit muddled for me I don't I
don't like the Batman stuff that's in
there I almost would have preferred this
to be a Gotham and a Joker that didn't I
don't like the scene at Wayne Manor
Wayne State yeah I do think they have a
lot of fun with the like Batman
iconography like one of the best shots
in the movie is when he like reaches
into his mouth to get the blood and like
paints the Joker lips on himself which
is like right out of a Batman comic and
like that's that's like how to really
use the imagery to drive what they're
doing home and like I like that's
nothing but yeah I didn't I don't really
know I mean not
does it make the timeline not work like
if this is the joke or how can Batman be
a little because Jared Leto is his son
beating up a 70 year old Joker yeah you
start really concerned about the
timeline it's like an Elseworlds thing
maybe in this version Batman and the
Joker never meet each other this is just
happening this iteration of Gotham City
or this generation I don't know I just I
I wouldn't have done the imaginary stuff
I think like people say Dex did you guys
watch Dexter yeah Dexter's stopped
working cuz how do you top the Trinity
Killer after in season 3 but I think it
stopped working because spoilers for
Dexter because they kill his wife they
kill Rita they tell his anchor to
humanity and he doesn't have Arthur
Fleck doesn't have anything like that in
this movie so there's no anchor yes to
connect him to there's nothing to like
root for him through like you want that
maybe does he have a connection to za z
beets very banker it was like a
progressive yanking out anchor yanking
the social worker his mother's Ozzy his
surrogate father again he was somebody
looking for connection over and over
again and then the the tragedy part was
he inspired this huge movement that he
he and the N no intention of yeah II had
no intention of starting right if this
was a not a tragedy he would have he
would have been like yes I am your
leader I finally got my family here
among the clown's but he didn't right
yeah which is in the fire yeah exactly
I think the anchors would have worked
better if he wanted them like in the in
his therapy he's always just like you
don't listen like he's never like I
desperately need this you know I think
he does because he's like Who am I gonna
go to get my medicine from I mean
there's a joker stuff is because they
cut all the funding and he can't get his
meds anymore yeah that's a big part of
it
like because they try to have it
everywhere there's like 12 explanations
and there they're trying to all and when
you're doing that it's sort of like well
then none of them feels like the
explanation like the movies kind of
about how many different excuses can we
come up with for him to do Joker stuff
as opposed to here's the story a to be
here's how this man ended up becoming
the Joker in a more clearly defined way
like I think that's kind of the that
doesn't mean that the movie has no value
it's something a great job I just feel
like then the movie just never pinpoints
what it's really safe I mean if you're
gonna the real Joker stuff of this movie
is I'm about to say something nice about
The Killing Joke which I don't want to
do but there is a strong piece of drama
around the idea of all it takes is one
bad day and you know the guy trying to
do the right thing and finally you know
giving in to that to that to that darker
sense and instead of all it takes is one
bad day this movie is just like
everything's bad right out the gate
I'm joking right out the gate area this
sucks I don't think he was Joker until
like pretty close to the end of the
movie like even at the very end isn't he
like didn't you get the sense he was
going out on Murray Franklin's show to
kill himself he was in the moment I
don't think he's the Joker until he
kills Alec Baldwin DeNiro he's gonna
play Thomas Wayne I confuse regardless I
like a movie where inspires this much
discussion around joke things rather
than I don't know how long do we talk
about guardians to is like Oz Bad's bad
so let's let's watch the honest trailer
and talk more it's a movie focus Brett
to break out of here this arc is the one
thing I could track Joe
[Music]
from the studio who won't release the
Schneider cut and this guy I'm sorry
you have the most beautiful feet with
feet is about psychological and social
decay with the bare minimum of Batman it
took to get the movie made there look
with the pearls and everything if that
word Batman's origin story wouldn't he
become clown man wouldn't the most scary
thing to him be clowns and he wanted to
take the power of clowns
I should add kind of clown mm-hmm I mean
you don't know he could also have the
like Chris Nolan like underground
Batcave by Wayne Manor that freaks him
out when he's like a boy like dramatize
does not seem at like off-screen
somewhere oh yeah I'd be like afraid of
guns gun man if I'd be afraid of Alfred
he's got a very stern Alfred could have
been sterner we'll talk about that you
think that was a studio note it needs
Alfred yes they need to put the Batman's
origin in the movie probably I to be
very much like a studio I think they
needed to do at minimum two bands there
will be a riot if if there is not Batman
stuff unless the Joker stay the scene
definitely feels like it's only there in
the present movie so that later when he
confronts Thomas Wayne he's like you're
the guy that was my house that was at my
house the other day like that's the only
context for it right so yeah I know I
think it feels like it felt like a
studio note to me I don't think it was
necessary and the huge Batman but I was
just even I was just like I don't care
about Batman right now I don't care
it's not necessary and then you really
don't need to go back to crime but we
all know what happens in be like okay
[Music]
we're walking on the riots going on I
can I'm a big kid I can go hmm yeah I
don't need to walk into crime there's a
sign that said crime out plays comically
now because we've seen become a joke
because we've seen it in movie so much I
don't think there's any way to shoot
that scene that I wouldn't chuckle at
now and that's the real Joker stuff but
Wayne not winning father of the year in
this universe oh no there's a clown
right go to the pictures see ya see
what's playing
well it wasn't starting there wasn't
gonna go when the movie started it's
like it's like it was raining when you
get it or is it sort of a parasite thing
of like Oh what are the pores doing yeah
we're going to seize our oh yeah sorry
let's get [ __ ] thing happy joker prepare
for a film the media said was too
dangerous for you to see which made
audiences way more excited than regular
marketing ever could have cruising its
way to improving dollars on a 55 million
budget because it got hyped like a
cinematic fear toxin that would turn you
into the Joker even though it ended up
being a mobile core Scorsese brief about
the world satis cloud hey which movies
turned you into the protagonist I've
been watching Ironman for 12 years and
I'm still a [ __ ] sure it's impalas
decade or so where it's like this media
will turn you into a psychopath red
matrix yeah right the post column is
matrix the Columbine kids coat so the
trenchcoat mafia they dressed like the
majors and I think I mean videogames as
long as they've been around yeah and
look I think that the the rebuttal to
that aside from I can't pull any
research out of my butt but it's like
it's an r-rated movie for a reason like
I wouldn't show this to a child because
children can't tell fiction really
they're idiots yeah
otherwise a lot of that stuff too was
just based on there was all this stuff
before the movie came out that was like
it's gonna be this rallying cry for
angry young white men and this is like
the insel movie and like people were
already freaked out about that stuff
because of other things that are going
on in America and politics this table
can attest we've all been yelled at by
people with joker avatars but it also as
part of and then and and I'm going to
talk about my own profession or
part-time fresh in you for a little bit
part of it was because it premiered at
Toronto in Venice in the film festivals
that it became it got enrolled and what
I sometimes like to call the critical
impacts which is the the the critics
that get to see these movies first
oftentimes will engage in a hyperbole
off to see who can get the best we can
get the most reads who can get the best
pull quotes and who can you know get
their names on the most the most stories
and stuff and so I feel like Joker while
I found it to be and if you go Michael
watch there be Rothen I both are very
disturbed by the movie because it's I I
think I still think it's a disturbing
journal especially the first time you
see it but I think that it also partly
got mixed up into a hot take of Palooza
from people that had seen it to people
that hadn't seen it or just like okay
how can we how can we be in more
inflammatory than the other one because
right now no one else has seen it but we
have and that's not to say that all
critics and all people to see movies
early are disingenuous because they're
not but a lot of times I have found and
I will observe and even I'll just kind
of shake my head sometimes with the
great movies and with with movies that
aren't so great like when emoji movie or
cats comes out there's often a hyperbole
off of sure who can love it the most /
hated the most / come up with the
biggest story I don't even think it's -
you're right there's an incentive to
hype it or trash it more than you would
normally but I think that there's maybe
a genuine feeling of when you see
something at a festival or at a premiere
or whatever it feels different
they are seeing it's
Game of Internet telephone it's like the
people who've seen it had their
reactions and then people who haven't
seen it read those reactions and then
they report it to others about the
reactions that the others and then it
spreads and it often ends up being a
story about a movie that doesn't really
have that much to do with the movie and
I think in this movie especially when
you would be reading a lot of the
discourse around it then you'd see the
movie be like well this was really
different from what the discourse was
and I think that fed a lot of the like
real terror around this movie the people
just had a weird idea of what it was
because that's how Twitter works I think
one critic said like this is an in Cell
rallying cry and then like people took
that one tweet and then they tweeted it
right teen thousand times and so that
one person's are those few people's
thoughts on the movie became the
narrative about the movie because this
tiny fraction of the voice got amplified
500 times exactly that's justifying the
anger and domestic terrorism and all
this stuff and then you watch the movie
it's like it's about a sad clown man
Flyers angry cloud but shouldn't have
been a tell when it like won the Toronto
Film Festival and like it was some kind
of a furry animal that was golden note
aureus in sales at the venice film came
out like michael moore's coming out
calling it a masterpiece this is where
we need to shout out the real Joker of
all of this ben Meckler on twitter daily
onions thing this is my favorite of
pista if you don't know who Meckler
anytime movie comes out all the websites
just blindly pull Twitter like pull
quotes and he just makes them up and
everyone always falls for them and
they're great but his Joker ones Jerry
Jerry the festival was like Joker got
into our hearts most of the critics and
I have taken to the streets we flipped a
car we've been running
we've been running it's been hours
beautiful keep doing keep doing what
you're doing
I hope phantom slash scream journey to
1980s Gotham where the garbage is high
the klom rental business is booming
wanna clown for everything is yellow
from this bourbon saucer joke over rise
in Arthur fly and if marvel is known for
making their heroes get ripped DC will
one-up them by making their Star get
ribs he's a loner who deserves all your
sympathy for being poor and mentally ill
but earns all of your contempt for being
a viral video star in one of the
comedian he's got the faded hoodie and
everything rejected joke that is also
the hoodie is I don't know if it was
intentional or not a recreation of his
wardrobe from the village there you go
yeah I was just gonna say the viral
video thing who's taping that open mic
night in early make this one tough right
Murray Franklin gay I guess the how they
also host video feed but lake or there's
just a guy with a huge VHS catch the VCR
that's in a bag it's a callback to that
era in late night TV where they were
just like we have an hour to fill every
night and like nothing and so we're just
gonna like here's a crazy guy from the
neighborhood you know like how Letterman
used to have like the guys who made his
sandwiches at the deli we couldn't
figure out remember we debated was
Murray Franco let's show a national show
local show I think it was local Gotham
is so big that it went up to New York
then it's national but if it's not I
think it's a local big it's awesome I
think it's local but it like eight
million people watch it because it's in
Gotham I mean he's probably like like
Carson Daly
like after the national ones and there's
there's the kid like do you have like
dr. roof on at the end or something like
that's that's a throwback to Johnny
Carson but yeah in the 80s I would have
been huge so yeah I think it's I think
he's the know the Fallon of his day but
Carson I mean it's obviously riffing on
the Carson show yeah the animal pride
doesn't he have somebody from the zoo
come on at one point Ed McMahon guy yeah
it's supposed to be like Carson right
anyway to keep going median which lady
was podcast go back to the oven Michael
and she has true self contempt so just
watch the world burn now this version is
here to teach you a lesson you should
show more compassion for the mentally
ill or they'll snap and kill you but
this joker has a few eunuch tricks up
his sleeve
like the superhuman capacity to pay the
elderly jump stop sleep in a
refrigerator joke stop someone wrote
like that's the mister pencils right
yeah mister on his forehead just damage
his forehead superpowers quick before he
turns 12 and overpowers it is there a
blu-ray special feature of just the
Dolby artist doing the headbutt sound
effects oh yeah just what exactly they
were using to create be like sound we're
free to speculate Todd Phillips said
that there are no they film stuff that
wasn't in the movie but there will be no
deleted scenes I'm skin gray yeah this
is the Phillips cut and he did something
in the in the bath or in something they
were so twisted like oh man it wouldn't
even gotten our rating would have been X
sure you didn't the bad
[Laughter]
no guys there's a baby and the Joker's
gonna pretend that it jerks off Mike
Tyson's gonna pretend that jerks off Ken
Jong's in the tub with them I'd like to
see Todd Phillips Joaquin Phoenix then
like the co-writer sit around trying to
figure out what it should be meeting I'm
just gonna ask the question where
they're sign spinners in the 80s because
I don't remember them I think that was a
modern in me I don't like sandwich board
guys with the trickery you know we
should hire a sign for the stern that
people are gonna like call some clown
talent agency you just hire one of you
one of you made the note and we were
like a block down there's just a sign on
like a yeah honest and pointing someone
like the piano guy I thought that was
like the soundtrack no it's a music
store yeah so the guy but I would be
like why why the piano guys a great draw
just like
two piano guys next to each other she
works in your store has like a kid
brother who comes spin aside outside you
play you don't need a clown agency to
hook you up with a clown just
specifically spin side like oh we're
spending this time we're gonna want a
pro clown you don't want to go with some
ranking at this point if you need to eke
out that living and you're not one of
the big clowns like bozo you've moved to
the Bay Area you go you go to Pier 39
and West City where's the flash from 39
getting arguments with the jugglers once
a week on who gets the prime spot okay
five minutes about spinning a sign and
got a fight that's good good experience
a film with one of the all-time great
Joaquin Phoenix gangly loner
performances and what are the let's say
third most uncomfortable Joaquin Phoenix
interviews suggesting some even more
awkward laughs I'm sure so I have a
large frog in my hand it's just
something's calling out of my scalp that
shows the greatest actors of our
generation present range from laughing
normally to laughing because of a
medical condition - laughing maniacally
[Music]
to cry laughing - every laugh in between
this one sounds like a pug yeah I I know
I'm twisted and like to do Joker stuff
but there were there was there was one
point in this movie that I genuinely
laughed out loud night made me feel bad
for it is what his gun falls out we
meant to be funny I think that's one of
them my favorite is when he's doing his
famous dance on the steps and then we
till tough to see Shea Whigham and Bill
camp as the cops just like it was not so
that's obviously meant to be funny
that's in there as a joke I wanted more
stuff like that in the movie I just
thought it worked better than burying
you with sad like I liked the gun thing
and the children saw that was so so good
a guy who kind of knows how to like
timing like that's his that's his bit
definitely wanted a whole lot more of
that comedy yes
I wouldn't like hangover three levels
yeah I think those moments worked for me
the those character moments
I mean the stairs is a little Looney
Tunes but like the the children's are
not learning but like it's ridiculous
yeah like the Children's Hospital scene
where the gun pops out that that's super
fun that tells his like reaction and
that tells me more interesting stuff
about the character than like I don't
know
I like things quietly okay told
anne-marie Franklin I thought was funny
see for me yeah laughs in a movie like
this act as a as a release valve and I
know I would I don't think you want to
do that I think this whole movies about
ratcheting tension I think if you put in
laughs then you just be releasing the
tension every 10 or 15 minutes and uh
then your watch and throw ragnar yeah or
something I don't know the whole plan in
that one yeah good characters Joker to
pull the pull the the release valve and
I think the tension built it how did I
go from in the middle to defending it if
it's like like a Jurassic Park people in
the only my side all right let's keep
going let's see if we can finish within
two hours I know you think of service
centers are loving and dancing would be
more Abid but the other 30% is getting
the crap kicked out of him
[Music]
and the message is going to be and I
know then just in case you've missed it
because the true villains of Joker are
uncaring billionaires misogynist Wall
Street jerks he's being nice to you lack
of government funding the city's cut
funding across the board Social Services
is part of that and easy access to guns
we've got a protected class that's a
weight
it wasn't an insulin cry or an anti sjw
screed how is it possible that every
heartache about this movie was wrong
including the directors so absolutely we
could probably do another hour on the
local culture comedy debate the larger
point is I think we talked about it we
talked about this already is all the hot
takes didn't match up with the film
itself yeah we actually had an expanded
version of this where it was a lot of
like this stuff Todd Phillips said in
the aftermath of the movie coming out
they were just like you're not you're
not you're not helping right yeah yeah
there you go
counterpoint and your movie just made 1
billion dollars you know well there you
go
no oh yeah no a series it yeah yeah no I
don't know again I'm not sure he know
something yeah I think like I I made
light of the hangover 3 but I'll also
make heavy of it it's not funny movie
and it's because of what culture it's
because a lot of these things are hack
at this point like it does change about
every 10 years and the same things
aren't as funny as they used to be and
that's perfectly fine but yelling a slur
at somebody is just like it's not funny
it's not funny
like like of the many many problems with
that kind of humor
one of them is that it's just it's kind
of cheap and not funny and there's a
while that it kind of skated by own
shock value but that's like shocked
aside your personal feelings on slurs
and stuff like that yeah for me bad but
there's a comedy reliance company relies
so much on surprise that when you lose
the element of surprise and you know
what the joke is gonna be it's going to
be then it's not funny anymore
eventually it's not funny
find something new joke comment like
gives away that he thinks it's not a
question that there is any dip in
quality from hangover 1 2 3 like for mr.
person's like will you loved hangover 1
and you don't love hangover 3 so you
guys changed man it's like no no I'm
making the same jokes over again against
old culture killings it's not such a
fresh material yeah anyway so that's my
rant keep going
the directors so enjoy a joker movie
that's such a thoughtful challenging
comic-book movie it almost qualifies as
a movie movie with a take on the iconic
character that perfectly fits our
current day and age that isn't fun like
the 60s innocent like the 80s grim like
the 2000s or embarrassing like the 2010
but exists less as a story than a piece
of content to hysterically react to that
immediately forget until the next
outrage comes along everybody just yells
and screams of each other I'm so sick of
the society it makes me so mad I'm gonna
lose it and do Joker stuff mom get in
the bag
read Jambo / don't trust us see an
apartment she's imaginary you are not
the father will wane don't you go round
and round or even L I heard you paint
faces hey Arthur
are we cool and stairs
[Music]
seems too good to pass up
it's an old gag
in this video you know what for
reference Dance Dance Revolution great
title these finance guys know all the
words to send in the clowns model a
night Sondheim sessions with the boys it
was popular it had there were versions
of send in the clowns on the radio yeah
it was like a number one on Billboard's
like these guys would know all the words
to twist it alternate reality launched
yes everyone's this is a very clown
intense world like they have clown
rental industries guys are singing clown
stuff that works right I guess it's like
from that era before everyone was scared
of clowns clowns were just more
prevalent like today you're taking a
risk you're alienating part of your
customer base if you put a clown on
something yeah no yeah in this reality
like a clown is a status symbol all
right let's see what we cut out of this
one mmm
story I've just almost definitely
infectious laughter you should get
checked out he is the dancing thing
my flak Walker winos red-nosed a ribbed
for your pleasure the Clown Prince of
Crime stop when my clown will shoot
smother some dents her skyler dirty
Manic Pixie dream girl okay boomer
screwed
Geoffrey batman begins puberty and outer
Pennywise cosmic break bad Wayne Mathers
the childish man Jerry Langford Court
nominee love the gates and Mark Marin
doing in this dirty dancing get ready
the day the clown cried get some popcorn
the Scorsese he started back grab a
drink
the notebook not done yet funny people
still going laugh riot more coming the
Clown Prince of comedy still got Batman
Begins and in our decade or so
remember when late-night talk shows used
to just bring on random local weirdos to
feel time in 2020 are they would have
had to place categories with Channing
Tatum for a segment so wait is e Thomas
Wayne son no parents names are Batman's
only weakness this doesn't work as the
Joker's origin he's gonna be 60 by the
time Batman's old enough Oh No is he the
Joker's dad ha this film really goes out
of its way to show compassion towards
people suffering from mental illness or
else they'll kill you yeah there you go
laughs everything we cut from joke are
we left it long because we left
everything twisted in the trans notes
you see him like pop his head up over
the hedge at Wayne Manor security
ridiculous like bothering young master
Wayne all the time kidnapped a time if
you and I was gonna say about Alfred if
you see a lanky clown man give your
little boy flowers and then stick his
fingers in their mouth immediately
trying to get away from the scary media
all right but y'all had joke of thoughts
nhien snub right future DC movies
responding to Joker's success well I
think we're getting a joker chew
regardless like obviously they're not
going to make Aquaman like a fish
salesman in the gutter so they're gonna
take the wrong idea to make a bunch of
r-rated movies that are terrible instead
of investing in original projects that
are risky yeah well to me I think that
to do more Joker stuff just in name only
jaws if you will you probably will see
more genres that you can sort of do this
with like let's take a kind of movie
that maybe we haven't been making as
much but figure out an angle to put
these kinds of characters yeah Mario's
in it so that there's familiarity now
that we know that it or they're gonna be
really obvious mashups at some point
we're just gonna be like Wally West the
Graduate next
like Harley Quinn in One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest you know do that in Arkham
like kinda thing I think a lot where
it'll be like here's a here's a kind of
movie we used to make mash it up with
this like well thank you know like when
they came up with the idea like fast and
furious + heist movie equals goal ain't
ya alright well there you go sir fans a
lot I wonder if he'll appear in birds of
prey I will bet you he will not I will
walk out of so let's see if we couldn't
address that one already
Patrick Paul 12:03 writes what are your
thoughts on this I feel uncut gems hit
many of the same notes and had many the
same messages but was a better movie
screen junkies your thoughts well uncut
gems made the mistake of not putting
spider-man and uncut I don't know this
is I'm sorry if this was yours but
somebody wrote like uncle James would
have been anger make it a billion
dollars if they just call that of
sailors character the Riddler the
gamblers yeah I think that there are
some similarities in the sense before
like that it is a tragedy it's a man
succumbing to his weaknesses rather than
overcoming them and yeah it's a better
movie but like I don't know I think I
like the Joker more because I grade it
against other comic book movies and when
I when I widen the field to include
movies yeah uncut gems does better I
mean yeah I I agree with some guy I
preferring cut gems as a film where does
uncovering for you in the MCU I'm
talking any of the same notes though I
guess it didn't do that really did do
that for me I mean I guess it has
similar aesthetics at times and a
similar tone he was kind of putting you
in the mindset of a character sort of on
the fringe who doesn't really think like
most people I didn't see them as very
similar much more kinetic experience for
me than Joker Joker is very
yes takes its time and to kind of sit on
moments and I feel like I'm customer civ
character studies is kind of like how
fast can we get you into panic attacks
all right Mariko true rates
I would guess honest traitors require
multiple viewings of the movie by
yesterday staff drew whatever agender
food product was used to keep everyone
happy okay anyways in a non psychopathic
way how do we not go crazy
watching Joker over and over or do they
thank you for assuming that anyone cares
about our heads yeah that's really what
do they mean psychotropic way oh yeah I
don't know what drugs
Joker pairs well with I doubt any no
Trump cut my social services so I don't
have access to my medication oh yeah our
snack situation is pretty drinks tips
yeah steal people's lunches piranhas
boring and I'm so sorry to you guys but
all the behind-the-scenes questions is
just imagined
dunder-mifflin more chuckling it's not
insane seasons you know yeah yeah yeah
we owns having an affair with the sound
man now
here we have not done any parkour yeah
no chillin shows up in costumes like the
raids each other's beat farm or whatever
I did drive into a lake last alright
that's it for Joker I hope you all come
back next week for a much more boring
couple movies the clue is they're boring
and they suck we'll see that's true hope
you enjoyed this and hope you enjoyed
next time on all trailer come what do
you get when you get a bunch of comedy
writers with a bunch of crappy movies
Joe snapped
[Music]
you